son muchas las posibles fuentes de
inspiración para bailar en 1937 frank
roosevelt iniciaba su segundo mandato
con un icónico mis queridos compatriotas
no parece que byd en vaya a imitar el
estilo de harry truman se limitó al
periodista court en morning que había
pronosticado su derrota
[Aplausos]
también un cartel de papel a poco y
había todo
mucho más sobria fue la toma de posesión
de su sucesor en 1953
una jura habitual que repitieron john
kennedy
también lyndon johnson o nuevo en 1973
richard nixon lanzó un mensaje que
caducaría muy pronto
en el caso de giroud ford decidió jurar
con la primera dama a su lado jimmy
carter- optó por un discurso de nuevos
tiempos que bien podría inspirar al aire
style
accionarios el demócrata dejó el mando a
ronald reagan quien reivindicó la
transición de presidente un mensaje que
hoy bien valdría para donald trump veces
es salaam en muchos momentos se case
con george bush padre en su inauguración
ya hablaba de la unidad de los
estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
y más poético fue bill clinton en 1993
we force de mensajes para la historia en
una jornada de gran expectación como
demuestran las masivas posesiones de los
últimos presidentes george bush y barack
obama es algo muy fuerte y la del
presidente saliente de donald trump